bad at sex so it's like you get a little
bit of sex and you know and it's are you
really bad or just saying that because
you're comedian no I'm pretty bad at it
no I was good when I was young when I
was young dude [ __ ] yeah you know but
now I probably chat with you yeah
possibly we do like some mutual
masturbation maybe some sex sweet mutual
masturbation is the best yes very
thoughtful at a certain point it is yeah
some of it I think is just kind of
evolving you know it's like sometimes
nothing like if you're still [ __ ]
somebody you're sometimes like just a
weirdo I think sometimes but then
sometimes you got to let the beast out
of your heart you know and I sometimes
you know I just I don't know man it's
called it's just so there's so many
feeling sometimes going on inside of you
when you're trying to deal with like
love and sex but I'll tell you what I
revert you know why know is because of
the fact that you you got sober yeah and
how much abroad do you have now let me
see 11 a little over 11 months yeah and
when that happened yes your mind clears
yeah and new emotions arise you have to
learn how to deal with life on life
terms
yeah and this is what you're dealing
with right do you feel more on your dick
since you've been sober I feel a little
more out of my dad kind of out of your
day yeah really
OD OD cuz I feel like drunk sex I never
really feel I can't even like climb
nothing there's drunk sex it's just fun
the idea is fun right
during but you never remember the actual
pleasure from being drunk and having sex
you smell in your clothes that's what I
like really yeah the grime the idea is
amazing but the actual fact the actual
part of doing it drunk is only fun at
the time that you're drunk that's that's
the only time even remembering its neck
and fist-fighting and [ __ ] Armor was
more fun when you were drunk you know
yeah okay yeah we're just crazy what
what is that is what I like to change
though in your life in you know I think
I just yeah I mean I do you know it's a
good point you bring up cuz I feel like
I do have more feelings now you know and
I feel like you're clearer to be honest
with you definitely yeah I see your face
yeah it's just like a farmer like just
the complexion is a little healthier
yeah and you seem health just a
healthier in general thanks about yeah
yeah appreciate that man and I know that
you're taking it seriously because you
know I'm silver to an a I get this you
know observing you yeah farm and I know
that you're active and you're doing it
you know and that's that's great yeah
man I appreciate that dude it's good and
I mean the interesting thing is how many
other people you meet and we're doing it
and it's just that's the kind of thing
it keeps you going a lot of times you'll
just be like ah and then somebody else
will tell you a story or you meet
somebody else who's in the program and
it's just like okay yeah you know there
is something going on here
something magical kind of yes a lot more
people in the boat than you thought
initially cuz there's I mean even since
I've met him I realized that it's like
so many people are actually sober yeah
and who are fully creative people and
who are act just as wild as Bobby like
when people see him the perception is
always oh he's either by or you know
yeah he's like a travesty something good
that we got released from another
country deal look at me though wouldn't
it be a great movie it's like we get
back one of hours from Bobby's country
but they also have to save Bobby they
like some POWs but we also like we gotta
get rid of
[Laughter]
yeah you think I'm a disaster I'm a
disaster or what no what do I think when
I see you like do you think Hmong I
think I see like uh kind of like a
cocaine cartoon that kind of jumped off
the page and has been running from his
drawer you know yeah oh that's what I
feel like you just saw the run from your
artist all right and you're just doing
whatever you can and just stay on the
lam you know when you're hanging out
here with this guy in the closet and big
whitey here ginger root right here means
Michael Landon over here except but yeah
I mean uh I don't know you weren't the
only committees that makes me laugh just
by seeing you so you have a special gift
I think it's a nice look you have but
it's not because people hate when people
do that like Eric Griffin said that did
he
you just you just walk around and you're
just like this man but he's probably
jealous of it though look at his bone
[Music]